so what do you think about another
language of JavaScript that's this well
let me just sort of comment on what I
said when I was brought up sort of
JavaScript pasina's the probably like
the ugliest language possible and yet
it's quite arguably quite possibly
taking over not just a fun in the
backend of the internet but possibly in
the future taking over everything
because they've now learned to make it
very efficient you know so what do you
think about this yeah well I think
you've captured it a lot of ways when it
first came out javascript was deemed to
be fairly irregular in an ugly language
and certainly in the academy if you said
you were working on JavaScript people
would ridicule you it was just not fit
for academics to work on I think a lot
of that has evolved the language itself
has evolved and certainly the technology
of compiling it is fantastically better
than it was and so in that sense it's a
absolutely a viable solution on backends
as well it's the front-end used well I
think it's a pretty good language I've
written a modest amount of it and I've
played with JavaScript translators and
things like that I'm not a real expert
and it's hard to keep up even there with
the new things that come along with it
um so I don't know whether it will ever
take over the world I think not but it
it's certainly an important language and
where's knowing more about there's this
may be to get your comment on something
which JavaScript and actually most
languages of Python such a big part of
the experience of programming with those
languages includes libraries sort of
using building on top of the code that
other people have built I think that's
probably different from the experience
that we just talked about from UNIX and
C days when you're building stuff from
scratch what do you think about this
world of essentially leveraging building
up libraries on top of each other and
leveraging them yeah that's a very
perceptive kind of question one of the
reasons programming was fun in the old
days was that you were really building
it all yourself but the number of
libraries you had to deal with
quite small maybe it was printf or the
standard library or something like that
and that is not the case today and if
you want to do something in you
mentioned Python and JavaScript and
those are the two finding examples you
have to typically download a boatload of
other stuff and you have no idea what
you're getting absolutely nothing
I've been doing some playing with
machine learning over the last couple of
days and gee something doesn't work well
you pip install this okay and down comes
another gazillion megabytes of something
and you have no idea what it was and if
you're lucky it works and if it doesn't
work you have no recourse there's
absolutely no way you could figure out
which in these thousand different
packages and I think it's worse in the
MPM NPM environment for JavaScript I
think there's less discipline less
controller and there's aspects of not
just not understanding how it works but
they're security issues is there Busta's
issues so you don't want to run a
nuclear power plant using JavaScript
essentially Oh probably not
you